apple and nvidia are going to war over
the claims for having the world's
fastest computer gpu and the craziest
part is that they're using two
completely different methods to get it
done with apple going all out on
performance per watt with their 128 core
m1 max quadra gpu while nvidia is
literally just throwing metric tons of
power at its upcoming rtx 4090 as i'll
show you in just a minute and i'm also
going to be covering a wide range of
topics like chip shortages and how they
could be getting a lot worse for pc
buyers while apple is actually in a
really good position with their upcoming
multi-die chiplet designs and then we've
got to discuss the brand new performance
and price leaks for nvidia's rtx 4000
series and then finally why buying a
high-end mac might be a more
cost-effective choice if you need insane
levels of graphics performance so let's
get right into it just the other day a
digit times report came out with brand
new details about the upcoming rtx 4000
ada lovelace gpus that are extremely
positive from a performance point of
view and that comes after a bunch of
other details that have already come out
but before we dig into what all of this
could mean for these new nvidia gpus
we've got to discuss apple's major plans
mark german who was the most reliable
apple leaker out there has already
confirmed that apple is working on much
more powerful chips with two and four
times the number of cpu and gpu cores
than their current m1 max chip and the
way they're going to do this is by
literally taking those ammo max dies and
combining them together into a single
system-on-chip package by using some
form of high bandwidth infinity fabric
to connect them all together to minimize
efficiency loss and in one of my
previous videos i actually estimated the
performance of the four die m1 max
quadro chip in terms of the cross
platform 3d mark wildlife extreme
benchmark which simulates gaming
performance and the new chip
outperformed the absolute best record
score ever which was an insanely
overclocked rtx 3090 but when you look
at the 30 90 cards with an out of the
box overclock of around 1.8 gigahertz
the m1 max quadra is now around 63
faster than the 3090 which is super
impressive and if you're curious about
how i did those calculations i took the
32 core m1 max which already has
basically perfect four times scaling
compared to the eight core and one chip
and then i multiplied it by four but
then i took out ten percent to account
for some efficiency loss since the four
dice have to communicate between each
other which could add in a bit of
latency however there is a chance that
we might not even see a 10 efficiency
loss because of tsmc's very impressive
kawas packaging technology that they're
working on right now allowing multiple
triplet dies to communicate through an
ultra high bandwidth low latency silicon
interposer which is stacked onto the
package substrate that holds it all
together and frederick orange on twitter
recently pointed to a new die to die
interconnect technology from synopsis
with up to 112 gigabits per second
bandwidth per lane which is something
apple can use to connect two or four
dice together but the point that i'm
trying to make is that the technology
needed to combine multiple dies like
what apple is planning on doing is
already here and in the works but the
best part about going this route is that
every component within each m1 max die
will be put to use so the m1 max quadra
will have eight sets of video encoders
including eight prores encoders and
decoders compared to the current rtx
3090 which still has just a single set
of encoders and decoders it'll also have
16 thunderbolt 4 controllers
256 gigs of unified memory which can be
used as vram and of course 40 cpu cores
but the best part about all of this is
that apple's unified memory architecture
is extremely efficient because the cpu
the gpu and memory are all within the
same soc package which greatly reduces
latency for example matthew and ease
compared the 32 core m1 max gpu and the
new macbook pro to a desktop rtx 3080
gpu and in the only apple silicon
optized game that he tested which was
world of warcraft shadowlands the m1 max
was almost as fast scoring 180 fps
compared to 200 and then translating
that into performance per watt the m1
max completely blows the rtx 3080 out of
the water with almost 7 times the fps
per watt but of course there are barely
any games out there with full apple
silicon support so games that haven't
made the switch are not performing
anywhere close to as well which
definitely gives windows pcs a huge
advantage for gaming but now with all of
that mac stuff out of the way let's jump
into the brand new details we have
concerning the rtx 4000 gpus digi times
recently came out with a report claiming
that nvidia's gaming gpus are getting a
major refresh next year and apparently
it's going to be based on a new ada
lovelace architecture which will be
built on
tsmc's 5 nanometer node which is what
apple's current m1 max chip is built on
and interestingly they mentioned that
nvidia's data center gpus will be built
using tsmc's kowals technology which
means they could be combining dice
together in a package like what apple's
gonna be doing but for the regular rtx
4000 gaming cards nvidia is going to be
sticking to the traditional monolithic
ditec so let's get into what that means
first of all monolithic dyes are massive
just look at this image of the rtx 3090
die which is 628 millimeters squared
literally just by itself compared to the
entire m1 max die which is estimated to
be 429 millimeter squared which also
includes things like the cpu cores the
media engines the thunderbolt
controllers the secure enclave the
memory buses and much more and because
of that the monolithic dye is going to
be more expensive because larger dies
mean lower yields since you can't use up
as much of the edges of a silicone wafer
and if you have fatal flaws within the
wafer or the dyes you have to throw away
a larger portion of it but with apple's
multi-tie method they will have
immensely higher yields since the dies
on the wafer are much smaller and they
can combine them after the fact so it's
going to cost apple significantly less
cash per die and as far as the actual
prices for the rtx 4000 series we
recently got a report that those cards
will be around 10 more expensive because
tsmc recently announced a price increase
for their five nanometer wafers by up to
10
but luckily for apple tsmc is giving
them special treatment by only raising
prices by three percent just for apple
because they're expecting a higher
number of orders but because of the high
10 increase for nvidia some youtubers
like red gaming tech and gamer meld are
expecting the rtx 4090 to cost between
1600 and 1700
compared to the 3090s current msrp of
1500
but of course because of all of the chip
shortages going on including the whole
issue with scalpers reselling gpus the
real price of the rtx 3090 is actually
more than double that with the least
expensive 3090s out there selling for
over 3 000 right now and according to
nvidia ceo the pain isn't going to end
until at least the end of 2022. and to
make things worse there's a new
raptorium cryptocurrency that apparently
works best with amd's cpu processors
instead of using graphics performance
which could potentially cause a huge
shortage of cpus as well but in apple's
case everything is built into one
package and right now they seem to be
immune to the chip shortages because if
you order a 32 core m1 max macbook pro
you can get it before christmas and it's
at the same price as msrp unlike all
those graphics cards and the reason for
that is because apple's chips are
completely scalper proof since they're
built into the max so the point that i'm
making is that if these supply shortages
continue for the next couple of years
apple is going to have a huge advantage
with their m1 max quadra mac pro since
it'll be reusing these m1 max dies that
are already readily available so because
of that we could actually reach a point
where it'll make more sense to buy a mac
to get a seriously high level of
graphics performance instead of trying
to find an rtx 4090 which could be in
short supply and the m1 max quadra will
benefit from having up to 256 gigs of
vram and 8 sets of video encoders which
is currently the biggest limitation for
things like video editing however it
looks like nvidia is going to have the
upper hand in terms of performance
because we recently got new leaks of the
actual core counts that will be built
into the 4090 as high as 18
432 cuda chorus and apparently this
could mean a performance increase of 2.2
times compared to the 3090 which is
absolutely insane and this would mean
that the 4090 would easily outperform
apple's m1 max quadra but don't forget
that they're estimating it to also
consume a lot more power potentially up
to 450 to 650 watts which is
mind-blowingly high and according to
moore's law is dead on youtube going
above 500 watts with the rtx 4090 is
going to be a huge problem because
you're dealing with massive amounts of
heat that will need to be dispersed
properly or else you're going to be
losing all that performance potential to
thermal throttling or diminishing
returns but in apple's case four 32 core
m1 max dies are only expected to use
around 172 watts of power under full gpu
load which is much easier to handle and
cool down but even still the rtx 4090
will likely outperform the best that
apple will have to offer next year which
is very impressive the only question is
how bad are the shortages gonna be and
how high will the real price of this gpu
go thanks to all of the scalpers because
if things continue to go at this rate
buying an apple mac might actually make
more sense if you want a gpu powerhouse
but i guess we're just gonna have to
wait and see so there you guys go if you
enjoyed this video go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]